let me pull up the story we've got this
tweet from Matt taibi the Twitter files
Twitter files number one statement to
Congress the censorship industrial
complex and he posts this image it says
quote true content which might promote
vaccine hesitancy he elaborates in tweet
number 32. in one remarkable remarkable
email the virality project recommends
that multiple platforms take action even
against stories of true vaccine side
effects and true posts which could fuel
vaccine I'm sorry which could feel
hesitancy none of the leaders of this
effort to police coveted speech had
health expertise here you can see the
information being released standard
vaccine misinformation on your platform
and it goes on to say true content which
might promote vaccine hesitancy viral
posts of individuals expressing vaccine
hesitancy or stories of true vaccine
side effects this content is not clearly
miss or disinformation
but it may be Mal information
exaggerated or misleading also included
in this bucket are often true posts
which could feel hesitancy such as
individual countries Banning certain
vaccines I will say right now the things
that YouTube does not allow us to say
may very well be true and they know it
and they ban you from saying it anyway
because the people at YouTube are evil
people
Marjorie Taylor green got banned for
sharing vaccine information that was
self-reported from the vares system
which is a federal database Stephen
Crowder I think got two YouTube strikes
for discussing CDC data through
information that could promote hesitancy
they said which by the way the Veris
database is the industry standard that's
the one right because that's correct and
I remember talking to someone who does r
d in Pharma for for decades and and I
said well if the vares database because
I kept we kept getting fact checked
right you kept getting fact checked if
you posted something from the Bears
database and I asked a question I said
well is this true should we not use the
Veris database where do I go and they
said well of course we use the various
database what else would we use doctors
tell people that that's where they
should report it yeah the big the big
issue is from all of this
well I think we all knew but now we have
definitive proof I should say there's at
least an effort internally with the big
Tech government and this collusion to
censor real information from the
American people obviously I think
everybody who watches a show like this
and you guys and everyone who works for
or reads websites like yours or watches
a show like yours everybody knows you
know what I mean so how do we get that
information to these people who are
living in Bubble World they don't want
the information the Bubble World people
do not actually want facts they don't
want to know and when you give them the
information when you say hey actually
here's some facts they say no that can't
be because that doesn't make any sense
and it's like yeah this doesn't make any
sense you voted for these people this is
what you wanted you want to live in the
bubble now you are in the bubble and I'd
just like to say these people who are
pushing all of this stuff don't think
any of it's going to apply to them I
remember so distinctly when the ACA came
in and there were the Obamacare mandates
and at the end of the year you know if
you didn't have the proper health
insurance you got to find a whole bunch
of extra money and all of the lefties
that I was hanging out with in downtown
New York they were very pro-mandate for
the health insurance and then they all
got fined because they didn't have the
proper health insurance because everyone
was a broke ass artist right so then
they're like wait why am I getting fined
they don't think it applies to them
during the pandemic you'd go downtown
everyone's hanging out drinking whatever
the masks don't apply to them they want
to push this stuff on us and stay in
their bubble evil the Vanguard they're
the banality of evil there's the
banality of evil exactly and and they
know like the random Nazi guards who are
just sitting there scratching their
butts waiting these people will gladly
vote for your destruction and oppression
and then and then just ignore the rules
when it applies to them and go out
there's that viral video from New York
it's really funny it's like this street
corner with a bunch of bars that are
open and everyone's hanging out in the
street and they're drinking they don't
they don't care at all defying all of
the rules
enforce those people yeah no enforcement
this is why we call it anarcho tyranny
that's correct right so you you have
this you have people who will vote for
tyranny on those of you know so if like
okay total hypothetical but like Tim if
you or I let's say we were we were going
on a commercial flight and we had a
knife like we're done you're going to
get arrested you're definitely going to
get arrested you're probably going to
get Federal charge bro we've been
swatted 15 times a year and they've done
nothing exactly we've had this evacuated
for three hours because of a bomb threat
right so that's exactly what I was going
to get to that if someone's on the other
side and committing actual crimes
nothing will happen to them yep
whatsoever this is the system of anarcho
tyranny which gets to what you were
saying before that the establishment is
harnessing this energy it comes from
Tumblr and it you know originated there
and it got through the media and now
it's all you know spilling across
Tick-Tock like crazy like wildfire and
of course the Chinese Communist party is
just like boost boost
because they want to demoralize our
society which goes back to what you were
saying Libby that someone who's been
this is Yuri bezmanov right someone
who's been completely demoralized will
not accept accurate information you can
take them to Russia you can show them
the gulag they will not believe you it's
kind of Michael Knowles was on I just
saw this clip was on whatever podcast
and he was talking about how he's like
yeah I I met my wife when we were 10 and
we were kind of on again off again for a
while and then we got married now we
have a couple of kids and and they were
looking at him with that like it's like
the fluoride stare right yeah
just so confused right just confused
like
like are you and then they asked him are
you joking with us are you messing with
us and he said no that's that's just the
story of my me and my wife you know and
I get that sometimes when I talk about
Tanya and I say we met at a Bible study
and they say okay like come on no you
didn't like you guys met on some you
guys you you're a Handler knew her
Handler and then you you came and said
no you met a Bible study you've told me
the story it's very mutual I I some of
the people that were at the study still
follow us today and you know we're all
still friends Etc and so it's they
actually can't believe that these type
of things go on
because they're so used to the world
that's perpetuated by Hollywood this
hookup culture this world that's
perpetuated for example um there was
that video and and I've talked about you
know yellow stoning which is like the
new the new thing but there was that
video I guess it was a Ron Perlman movie
and he's he's walking up to a gas
station and I guess he's in the South
somewhere you I shared the clip recently
yeah and these guys and it's it's it's
it's a footage right it's not um it's
not supposed to be real and there's a
couple of white dudes in a in a pickup
truck with a Confederate flag and he he
grabs the flag off and he says you know
something man
that offends me you know why because I
read my history and those guys were
losers and that's what you are when you
fly that flag you're a loser and he
throws it and gets in their face and
like grows and I'm like
I've never had a couple of guys at a gas
station like that a costume flying a
giant like this this world doesn't exist
except in Hollywood movies and it's
liberal left-wing fever dreams that are
perpetuated to make people think and
then of course oh that's exactly what I
would do in that situation except that
world doesn't exist no I grew up in
Philadelphia area let me tell you
something like the gas stations that I
was looking over my shoulder at I wasn't
looking for you know a couple of dudes
with a Confederate flag you know I've
never had that situation and I've been
all over the country I've never had this
situation happen maybe that's because
you were the dude with the Confederate
flag how about that Jack whoa mic drop
whoa whoa why look why are you check
them out why are you flag checking me
Tim why are you flying I own your
birthday I would love to do a bit where
it's like he grabs the flag and throws
it on the ground and goes you guys are
losers and the guys just go hey hey come
on man you know it's trying to have a
good time you know
you know I'll just get my gas over here
well we're leaving we don't got no
trouble with you and like that's the
reality of what probably would happen
they'd be like oh like what are you
doing man why are you throwing up a flag
on the ground but that's the thing right
is my point is that that's how they view
fly over America that's how they view
places like Ohio places like East
Palestine where the you know just get
rid of their jobs shoot their jobs to
China who cares about them who cares
about the south they're all redneck the
only time by the way the only time that
you see the Midwest or the South
depicted in Hollywood other than a scene
like that is horror movies and that
you're like stranger things right which
is obviously hard because anyone anyone
worth anything in those places would
have already left that's the attitude
people have that's literally the way so
true that's the way that they behave
because I mean I mean I see it in in the
music industry and stuff like that you
know there are some bands that are like
man I love going to the Midwest because
that's the salt of the earth real people
and stuff and then there are some bands
that really like the coasts because the
snooty you know we're better than you
people are are are like they're the
trendy bands you know right and and you
really see that kind of attitude they
really do think that the people that are
worth anything have left the Midwest
because why would you stay why would you
stay and by the way I say that as a guy
from The Cut Libby you're we're both
from the East Coast yeah I'm from
Massachusetts yeah I grew up in western
Mass like you don't get much more
liberal than that you know nothing
western Mass I grew up when I started
playing shows I was playing shows in
Northampton that's where Smith college
is wow like that's where my yeah I grew
up living like it was the 90s so it
wasn't like it is today but like you
know I'm I grew up with with as as
Progressive uh surrounded by the most
Progressive people that you could come
up with in the 90s you know those are
very Progressive people yes although I
was actually uh I was talking to this
FBI former FBI agent who was out in
Portland in the summer of 2020 and he
said that the uh when they got their
mission briefing once they got out there
the officials in Portland were like you
know but we have to live out here so
that's why we got you guys out here
we're not going to do this work
ourselves we're very in favor of our
activists we really believe in their a
speech and when he turned in a report
showing that legal observers were
actually running cover for protesters
they nothing ever happened they like
didn't even acknowledge it that's not
Progressive anymore though no that's not
Progressive that's like tyrannical
that's that's that's authoritarian you
stop let's uh liberally so I do want to
before we before we get off gen six I do
want to to throw it out there because I
I tease this and I don't want to I don't
just leave it out so this whole question
about hey what's up with the rest of the
tapes right what is up with the rest of
the team so this this plan about giving
giving Tucker access first this is
something that I've known about since
you know second week of January going
back so that this has been totally in
the works but what people need to
understand is that there is a National
Security review going on right now with
all of the tapes and it's not just 14
000 hours it's 42 000 hours and
it's all going to come out and every
every piece because okay from a national
security perspective I'll put on my fed
hat for here for a second right you
can't actually show every person that's
going in and out of the skiff right
because you might have people that are
in cover that are going in there that
are that are checking this out you can't
show every route that they take the the
speaker and the vice president Etc
because they're safe rooms and different
areas and things like this so they want
to be careful with stuff like that but
as pertains to the actual people coming
in I've been told that as much of it as
possible is going to be coming out
they're reviewing all of it this is from
people uh close to the speaker's office
that it's something they've they didn't
actually have as a priority coming into
uh this it wasn't like you know some
deal or something like that I want to
say it wasn't a priority that's maybe
the maybe they rephrase that but they
realize how important this is and
they're actually making sure that they
can send as much out as possible and I
think that's amazing I think people are
actually going to be very happy when
they see what comes out do you know did
you see what McCarthy said today he said
because he was talking about this he
said you know uh that Tucker just had a
few
um
and that they asked Capitol Police if
there were any concerns and they came
back with one about like entrance about
like exits and things like that exactly
and then McCarthy said but it was
interesting that one that they had a
problem with Eric swalwell had had up on
the internet for the last two years
showing that part right because so I
mean this is uh you know JFK and Dealey
Plaza right to know the specific route
that a a principal is going to be taking
before they take it is an obvious
security risk for anybody McCarthy said
also that Pelosi's daughter had shown
the January 6 committee the exact route
to take from the speakers they showed
the route they showed the safe house on
Fort McNair so all of that is blown now
so now you have to completely change
that because now that's that's just
blown so if let's say you're some
terrorist group like an actual terrorist
group and you want to set up something
like this well guess what now you know
where all the principles of the US
government are going to go so as from a
security perspective the capital police
and probably in conjunction with the
Secret Service because remember the vice
president was there at the time are now
going to have to completely revamp all
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time